[Musique]
oui ma parole tekken 6 est mis seulement
lundi depuis 7 semaines à part à
l'automne je parle encore une fois d'un
enjeu qui touche les femmes autochtones
encore une fois au canada ce qui est pas
étonnant mais c'est quelque chose que
beaucoup de gens ignoraient et qui
commence à faire le tour des nouvelles
saveurs
la stérilisation forcée des femmes
autochtones au canada ce qui est assez
étrange et comment est-ce que ça l'a
fait là devant des nouvelles pourquoi
est-ce qu'on en parle aujourd'hui quand
c'est une réalité dont on parle et que
même été prise en comparant je demande
le gouvernement de monsieur trudeau dès
2018 comment ce à quoi stérilisation
forcée ça ne pas allumer des lanternes
chez les gens qu'on entend aujourd'hui
en 2021 est bien c'est que la chine
elle-même fait critique face à des
critiques face à son terme et mandé
femme ouïghoure et la stérilisation
forcée justement des familles go et je
vais premier réflexe qu'ils ont quand
quelqu'un les critiques sur sa c'est au
canada 2 1 mais vous non plus vous avez
pas régler vos problèmes avec les
communautés autochtones et la
stérilisation des femmes autochtones au
canada
on s'entend que c'est pas une forme de
racisme systématique et je le répète
constamment parce qu'il ya encore une
confusion par rapport à du racisme
systématique c'est des autochtones ont
dit et release et des formes de racisme
systémique c'est à dire que des
personnes en position de pouvoir qui
représente l'état comme la santé la
police comme tout les services qui vont
toucher aux communautés autochtones qui
sont pas des services privés mais bien
les services de l'état et bien comment
ces services doivent ont affecté dans
des formes de racisme justement les
membres la communauté est bien là
présentement on voit beaucoup dans
l'ouest il y avait des enjeux où il y
avait une stérilisation des femmes après
leur accouchement
on dit même que certaines femmes se
faisaient après le troisième but force
la cité l'elysée et souvent sans le
consentement ou sans la compréhension ou
moins en forgeant parfois et ça on va le
voir en cours parce que c'est pas encore
prouvé par la cour du canada mais ce
sont des allégations que les femmes
autochtones et c'est d'amener de la
vente depuis des décennies mais est bien
que les médecins le faisait sans
l'autorisation des femmes donc
comprenant quand les communautés
autochtones les personnes autochtones
comme imminente qui n'avait pas le droit
de dire ce qu'il voulait pour leurs
soins de santé pour leur corps et bien
sûr c'est une violation des droits
humains énorme au niveau international
mais même au niveau national parce que
qu'on parle de contrôle des populations
on voit ressortir des politiques qui
rappelle quand même une certaine époque
deuxième guerre mondiale pour pas sortir
justement le point godwin peu disert
c'est d'extermination de masse mais
c'est une forme d'extermination une
forme d' empêchement des communautés de
pouvoir avoir des enfants de pouvoir
exister regret leur population
donc comment est-ce qu'on peut même
qu'il y ait ce genre d'idéologie l'eau
au canada
ben c'est pas étonnant puisque pendant
longtemps aux états unis au canada des
politiques d'assimilation des politiques
de destruction de l'identité autochtone
du corps des femmes autochtones d'une
séparation des communautés autochtones
ont fait parti politique donc on peut
s'imaginer que ça la [ __ ] était
justement l'imaginaire de certains
médecins de pouvoir se permettre de
stériliser des femmes est de continuer à
le faire en toute impunité
jusqu'à ce que justement la
réconciliation soit quelque chose qui
soit ne la vend bien sûr beaucoup de
gens disent n'avoir pas finir cette
réconciliation
un jour oui on peut pas juste basée la
réconciliation sur maintenant on vous
voit maintenant où vous connais on
reconnaît votre histoire de maintenance
et comment aurais pas d'histoire
commandes effet le racisme qui a été un
briquet dans le système mais qui n'est
pas le système dont vous que le système
était parti de façon uniquement c70
d'heure on va se réaliser les femmes
autochtones non sens pas que pendant
longtemps les politiques qui étaient en
place permettait à des membres du
système de faire des actions raciste et
de pouvoir s'en sortir en toute impunité
et là je rentre même pas dans toutes les
autres enjeux parce qu'on en parle
constamment vous rend compte que la
surprise comme la surprise des
canadiennes soit à cause que la chine ne
critique sur ça ça parle beaucoup de
comment les veilles canadien est encore
à devoir être travaillés et avance alors
vous comprendrez que c'est encore un
enjeu énorme
on espère que vous enverrez des
questions en espagne dans le partage
vidéo n'hésitez pas non plus à partager
le format pas de gaz de mes chroniques
et en espérant que les prochaines les
prochaines chroniques soit beaucoup plus
joyeuse qui représente beaucoup plus un
aspect la guérison que le travail qui
est toujours être fait par les
communautés pour faire avancer je
commande aux droits humains de base
alors je fais une belle somme